President Trump is pushing forward with
a tariff reduction plan his goal global
markets continue to be rattled by the
intensifying us-china trade war the
White House is struck a deal closer to
home on Friday president Trump said
Canada and Mexico have agreed to drop
tariffs on American goods in exchange
for the u.s. scrapping tariffs on key
imports from those countries he's also
playing nice with Japan and Europe by
delaying a decision to slap tariffs on
foreign cars by six months we judge Aang
is at the White House this morning what
more can you tell us we do oh good
morning Michelle and to everybody so
those two-way tariffs between the u.s.
and Canada and the US and Mexico were
viewed as a major roadblock to sealing a
new North American trade deal which
President Trump is now confident can
move forward meanwhile his ongoing fight
with congressional Democrats over his
personal finances continues to escalate
we could have the greatest economy in
the history of our country speaking at
the National Association of Realtors
conference President Trump announced the
u.s. reached a deal with Canada and
Mexico to scrap tariffs on their steel
and aluminum imports which were in place
for nearly a year in return they will
get rid of retaliatory tariffs on US
products they've been charging us
extremely high tariffs as much as two
hundred and eighty five percent or more
for our agricultural products which is
an absolute barrier it's essentially a
barrier the president expressed optimism
the move will clear the way for a new
North American trade agreement the u.s.
MCA a renegotiated NAFTA that Congress
has yet to pass into law Canadian Prime
Minister Justin Trudeau agreed now that
we've had a full lift on these tariffs
we are going to work with the United
States on timing for ratification but
we're very optimistic we're going to be
able to move forward move forward well
in the coming weeks but on Capitol Hill
no progress was made in the ongoing
battle between the administration and
Democrats who
see mr. Trump's tax returns on Friday
both the IRS and Treasury Department
missed the deadline to comply with the
subpoena from the House Ways and Means
Committee demanding the past six years
of returns Treasury Secretary Stephen
minuchin responded in a letter writing
the committee's request lacks a
legitimate legislative purpose the
committee's chairman representative
Richard Neal the result will be that we
will likely proceed to court as quickly
as next week so congressman Neal says he
will consult with lawyers to decide
exactly how to proceed but he's already
facing criticism from some fellow
Democrats who want to see a more
immediate punishment for administration
members who blow off subpoenas but Neal
says he doesn't believe it's the best
option to hold minuchin or the
Commissioner of the IRS in contempt of
Congress Dana all right we just thank
you